I am certainly very much in favor of
assessment I think anybody who's at all
serious needs to know how he or she is
doing and as you become more of a
professional you do more of the
assessment yourself I'm I'm a writer and
I don't have to have as much editing as
I did decades ago on their hand
I might probably need more more feedback
on speaking than in writing because I do
more writing than I do than I do
speaking so assessment is great and
testing is a kind of assessment it tends
to be more formal namely you can assess
all the time testing involves sitting
down and doing something in a
circumscribed period of time
standardized testing means this is a
test that's done widely for many many
different kinds of people but it's under
done under standard conditions you show
up at 10 o'clock in a certain room maybe
with a number-two pencil or at a
computer station and you click and
there's certainly reasons why we like to
do standardized testing if for example
we want to know how American kids in
general are doing compared to 10 years
ago
or how American kids are doing compared
to Finnish kids sort of Turkish kids you
need to have those kinds of instruments
the problem is the United States we have
excessively valorized a certain kind of
test the short answer multiple choice
test and we do way too much of it
somebody once quipped that you know if
somebody's sick it doesn't help to take
their temperature all the time that
doesn't make them any better in America
now and even in 2015 President Obama
said we're doing too much testing the
notion is kids aren't doing well let's
test them over and over again all that
does is waste time that could be done in
educating kids getting them excited
about learning and so on so if you ask
Howard Gardner what does he think about
the whole environment what I would say
is certainly we should assess and we
should give feedback to people
conveniently in the way they can use it
there's certain reasons why we need to
have standard tests if we want to do
comparisons among populations but that
can be done by sampling you can find out
how United States is doing by assessing
1,200 kids of a certain age that's how
we
actually do public opinion polling for
for elections when it comes to applying
for highly selective colleges and
universities I think it's fair to have a
test like an SAT or an a CT but it's
really stupid to make that your only
measurement you should be liquid looking
in student work looking at
recommendations interviewing students if
you can letting them make a case for
themselves and importantly since I'm a
believer in firma t'v action if you have
two kids who get the same score and one
kid has had thousands of dollars spent
on a preparation you know by a Princeton
Review and the other kid didn't even
know there was such a thing as a test
prep then I think you know the 1,200 in
the latter kid is much more impressive
than the 1,200 in the former people
often say I want to have all my kids
intelligences tested and I don't dismiss
it but the first thing I say is how's
the child doing is their child thriving
is a child excited about things school
have hobbies have friends if kids are
fine leave them alone and just say a
prayer of thanks when the armamentarium
of intelligences becomes important is
when an individual is having some kind
of problem because then you need to know
what's the nature of the problem for
example is a child being asked to learn
something in a way that the child
doesn't have much aptitude for are there
other ways of getting at that kind of
issue and this is a challenge
particularly for teachers because
teachers job is to help everybody learn
certain things but there's no where is
that written they have to all learn it
in the same way when it comes to parents
what I always say is you have to avoid
positive narcissism and negative
narcissism positive narcissism is the
one thing I could do is play the tuba
and my child is got to play the tuba
negative narcissism is the one thing I
couldn't do is play the tuba and my
child must play the tuba what I say is
take your kid and lots of different
things go to museums go to parks go in
holidays watch what your child's
interested in and even more watch how
your child pursues those things that
will tell you what the child's
intelligences are and then you have a
choice do you want to nurture
you want to try to develop ones that
that aren't so good
I am definitely uneven in my
intelligence is like I think everybody
is but I have spent a lot of time trying
to bolster the weaker ones just because
I want to but I wouldn't have to do that
I could just go from strength